une station essence total transformé en
fonds marins des dauphins des tortues et
plusieurs coraux une action menée par
une quinzaine de militants greenpeace et
actions non violentes comme 21
objectif dénoncer les explorations de
l'entreprise pétrolière sur le récif
corallien brésilien à travers une
pétition
sa pétition demandent justement à total
d'abandonner ses projets de
d'exploration pétrolière à l'émotion du
fleuve amazone dans une zone en eaux
profondes et donc à risque
il ya le risque zéro n'existe pas et
donc un risque de marée noire qui
pourrait potentiellement être néfaste
pour la biodiversité du récif une
pétition qui a déjà recueilli plus d'un
million de signatures et les militants
écologistes tentent de sensibiliser
d'autres citoyens comme il l'aurait créé
un écosystème ça n'a pas de prix
et c'est important de protéger des
choses qui sont encore vierges de toute
action humaine c'est important
aujourd'hui me semble alors qu'on a une
trace qui est de plus en plus indélébile
sur la planète à l'environnement c'est
ce qui nous permet de vivre donc
forcément c'est important quand on voit
comment on pollue la planète avec tous
les diesels et
forcément que c'est important plusieurs
messages d alerte avec notamment la
défense des engagements inscrits dans
l'accord de paris lors de la cop 21 en
on avait décidé à paris de ne pas
dépasser les + 2 degrés en fin de compte
on se rend compte que si total continue
à forer
des sites pétroliers un peu partout
autour du globe ça va pas le faire ce
midi effectivement il ya eu donald trump
qui a déclaré vouloir se donner une
marge de manoeuvre le temps de réfléchir
aux engagements a priori c'est mal
engagé
une déclaration du président des états
unis lors du g7 à taormine en sicile le
respect des conditions de l'accord de
paris devrait revenir dans les débats
lors du g20 à hambourg les 7 et 8
juillet prochains